so I guess uh last time we talked about
um gaussian discrimination of analysis
I'll have a very brief review and um
and talk about some of the remaining
points that I didn't get time to mention
last time and then I'm going to move on
to another case about spam filtering
where we're gonna have uh discrete acts
instead of continuous acts so last time
we talked about gaussian discriminal
analysis and the general idea is that
you first
model
P of x given y and p of Y
and what we do is that we say p of x
given Y is a gaussian for y is 1 or y0
okay I guess I need to remember right
bigger so x given Y is equals to zero is
from some gaussian distribution with mu
zero and covalent Sigma and x given Y is
one is from some gaussian distribution
between one and sigma and recall that we
have this uh
illustrative situations where you have
some examples like this
these are positive samples there's an
active examples and you kind of believe
that each of this
subpopulation come from a gaussian
distribution with different means but
with the same covers so that's the
methodology we have that's the starting
point we have last time and then what we
do is that we say after you have this
probabilistic model we also we have this
P of Y is 1 is equals to V after you
have the probabilistic model then you
can learn the probabilistic model from
data by Noe so
so we learn by maximize
we take the arc Max
over our parameters Phi Mu 0 mu 1 and
sigma and we take the r The Arc Max of
the the log likelihood you know it's the
same as the likelihood you know Mac Arc
Max of the log likelihood is the same as
the max of the likelihood so I'm just
writing the log likelihood which is the
log of the probability
um
of x i given y i
plus the sum of the log of the
probability
y
under I guess you know technically under
this parameter
V mu 1 mu 2 Sigma
and
I guess technically I don't have to
write video just because it doesn't
depend on feet okay so that's the the
methodology and then we skipped a lot of
steps because these are homework
questions
um and and we told uh and they told you
that the solution of this mle problem
you can analytically solve it in this
case because this objective function is
nice enough it's a it's kind of like a
quadratic function so you can solve the
uh the maximization problem analytically
and you get
um some formula for uh these quantities
right so the formula for Phi was
something like
um something of this form
of this indicator function
which is here basically the numerator
here is the number of positive examples
and divided by the total number of
examples
and we also have formulas for Mu 1 and
mu 2 so mu 1 was something like the
average
of x i in the positive group
in the positive examples
so you take the average you divide by
the total number of positive examples
and you can also have mu zero and also
Sigma
so each of these has a formula which is
a Formula or that depends on the data so
this is how you learn the parameters uh
from uh from the data
and then we talk about
given these parameters how do you do the
test how do you do the the inference or
how do you do the
um the prediction right like when you
get we already learned these parameters
now you are given an example X how do
you predict y using the parameters and
given ducts right so and we said that
the you're trying to compute the arc Max
over the two choice of
y's and you want to look at which choice
of Y gives you the largest probability
given X
and given the parameter
and these parameters are the the
solutions you have computed from these
formulas
right so you compute which one oh sorry
not bad this is one you complete which
one has the largest probability and also
we discussed that you know to know this
actually you just have to you know in
some sense you you have a decision
boundary so uh the decision boundary
between the two choices is those cases
where
is this uh
those axes were that is where these two
probabilities are exactly the same so
where the P of Y is one given X is equal
to P of y 0 given X is equal to a half
right this is the decision boundary and
we have computed the decision boundary
which turns out to be something like a
linear function
so decision boundary turns out that this
P of Y is equal to one given X this is
equals to
um
this is equals to something like I guess
maybe I'll just directly write out the
decision boundary
we found out that the decision boundary
is the set of X such that
uh
Theta transpose X Plus Theta 0 is equals
to zero where Theta and Theta zero are
functions of the parameters that you
have learned there are some like um
specific formulas uh that um to describe
this Theta instead of zero which are the
homework questions but Theta says there
are some functions of Phi Mu 0 mu 1 and
sigma
so that's why when you really make the
prediction what you do is you say you
find out this decision boundary this is
the final of X such that Theta transpose
X plus zero is equal to zero and then if
this quantity is bigger than zero then
you'd say it's positive and if this
quantity is less than zero you say it's
negative
this is very quick you know Five Minutes
review of the last lecture very very
quick any questions
if we have multiple labels yeah there
will be a decision boundary for multiple
labels so um and um you you basically
just compute the decision boundary using
this methodology you're gonna get a
foreign
I think if you have the same covariance
the decision boundary is still linear
um but if you have different models you
may have different type of decisions
you know it wouldn't be a half because
you know you're gonna have multiple
choices wise here right so so your
decision module will be
like uh I think I think it's going to be
more complicated so you have to really
decide you know when suppose this is
like zero one two three or four right so
then you really have to just really
literally solve this right you have to
know when is the case what is the region
such that the maximizer of this is
equals to say label two so that's that's
gonna be something that describes by
some linear region some kind of linear
boundaries
but it's going to be more of conflicted
fall
you know it could be depending on what
probabilistic model you define right so
I think if stigma are all the same the
capital Sigma all the same I think it's
going to be linear and if you have
different segment even you have two
classes but just take my one and sigma 2
then I know it's as a fact it's
quadratic
I saw some other questions as well any
questions are welcome
okay
so this is just give you a quick
overview a quick review of what we have
we did last time
um and and you will see that our new
when we discussed the new problem we are
going to have from
similar methodology you define a
probabilistic model you solve the mle
you get some formula and then like you
get some parameters and they use those
parameters to predict what's the most
likely wise okay so but before going to
that I'm going to discuss one important
thing which you know many people
actually ask in the last lecture at the
end of the last lecture they are great
questions so the question I'm going to
discuss next is that you know why this
is different from what what we have seen
in the first two weeks right so at the
end of the day you have a decision
boundary which is linear right so
basically at least superficially it
sounds like you are using a linear model
to decide you are going to use this
linear function to decide whether it's
positive negative right you compare this
with zero and if it's paused if large
zero is positive otherwise is negative
and this is the same as the the logistic
regression that Chris talked about in
the first two weeks so why these are
why this is different uh from from the
uh the so-called discriminative methods
that Chris talk about so I think um here
is the the way I think about this so
um
so so if you have GDA on the left and
suppose you have like a logistic
regression on the right
um
so first of all in terms of the
Assumption they are different
so for GDA I guess I wrote The
Assumption there so you maybe I just
wrote here again so this is gaussian
and this is also gaussian
something like this and you also have Y
which is from Bernoulli
and when you do logistic regression then
you just literally say that
P of Y is equal to one given X
you
your probabilistic model assumes that
this has the form
uh one over one plus e to the minus
Theta transpose X
and and recall that here when you write
this in places we are saying that X zero
is one right that's quiz assumption like
in the first two weeks but suppose you
don't have that assumption you're going
to have another
suppose X doesn't contain X zero then
you need to have another set of zero
something like this right if you contain
the x0 then you are going to have a
clean form but they are the same right
because you know if suppose let's say
for today let's say x uh you drop that
convention so exciting contain x 0 then
you you're gonna write it like this
right and this exactly match the form
here
so
so basically you can see that one thing
is that for GDA you assume this bunch of
things and you and you found out that it
implies that y given X has this form
right so recall that okay maybe I didn't
write this but like this is equals to
one over one plus e to the
minus Theta transpose X plus zero
right so let's say how do I write this
so P of Y is equals 1 given X
right so this is a
this is a conclusion that we got
from the probabilistic modeling right
from our mathematical derivation right
we conclude that y given X should have
this form
and in logistic regression you just
directly assume it so in in GDA that's a
conclusion in some sense
right and
and I guess you know we have to stress
this many times so here you you you
model The Joint probability distribution
because given if you know x given Y and
you know why then you also have the
density of X comma y right but here you
only always have y given X but you never
have anything about X we only have the
conditional probability
so in some sense
the kind of like the the main difference
between these two is that on the left
hand side you have more assumptions
so
I think this is the key
you have stronger assumptions on the
left hand side than on the right hand
side
and and in some sense the color of the
journal
um
uh the general kind of like a phenomenal
General principle about you know how do
you model what what part of the world
you want to model in your machine
learning algorithm right so do you want
to model both or you want to model only
YG Max right so how do you decide when
what how much you want to model the
world so the the kind of the pros and
cons of the the kind of the trade-off is
that if you have more assumptions
then typically if if this is also
correct assumption
if your assumption is correct
then uh this pretty much implies you
have better performance
of course this is a not mathematical
statement but I think it's kind of
reasonably intuitive because if you have
more assumption it means that you you
are using your prior knowledge about the
world right so here you are using a
prior knowledge that x given Y is
gaussian and if you use that prior
knowledge typically if you use it
correctly then you should have better
performance like a like you know if I
tell you everything then of course you
have better performance but if I tell
you a little more I suppose I'll tell
you everything about mu and sigma and of
course your performance is the best
right if you tell you a little more
about X then you should always have a
little better performance
so but the problem is with this is that
so this is the the good thing about more
assumptions but the risk is that
you may have wrong assumptions right you
might have
make a wrong or approximate or kind of
like not exactly correct assumptions
right
right so if you make wrong assumptions
then make in most of the cases probably
GDA will will be worse out for example
what if the data are not really gaussian
right so what if this doesn't look
gaussian at all and you still make
assumption that they are gaussian then
you you're gonna have like a
um um worse worse performance
so and
um another thing I want to stress is
that even though superficially you see
the form here is the same right so Theta
transpose so when you make the GDA
assumptions you get this y given X of
this form but suppose you go through
this left hand side and get this and you
numerical you compute the source Theta
so Theta instead of zero it would it
wouldn't be the same Theta instead of
zero
um as you what you computed from
logistic regression
so you're gonna get a different side of
like Theta and say zero so that's why it
makes a difference so so this is a zero
from Logistics regression is how do you
get it you just directly fake your
leading model using logistic regression
that's how you gonna say that zero but
if you go from here to here then you're
gonna first learn the MU the sigma uh
the MU 1 mu two a mu zero mu 1 Sigma and
then you compute Theta using mu zero mu
one Sigma so so that will result in a
different set of theta instead of zero
that's why it does make a difference
um and whether it's better or not I
think as I said basically depends on
whether assumptions are are correct or
how correct your assumptions are
probably you never have can have like
exactly correct assumption but maybe or
something we all sometimes approximately
correct then you should do GDA if your
assumption is just completely wrong then
you probably should do logistical
question
any questions so far
um
like we have a different data in Mortal
cases so I will just be different again
like is it because we're Computing in
that equation of the out there
directly and using those formulas and
then you compute Theta as a function of
mu and sigma right so so it's definitely
a different process right you're not
getting the Theta instead of zero in
these two cases using the same process
right so in one process it's kind of
Securities right you first have to
compute mu and then say it's data and
the other case you just directly fit
this using a numerical algorithm like a
reading descent right
is it possible that you can get a
different decoration
X but we have let's say the premise our
shoes yep definitely you you may have
if you change your assumption you may
have a different equation for p of
Magnum X and there's an actual
interesting point I'm going to mention
maybe maybe after I answer are there any
other questions
okay so then
there's actually another interesting
point I'm going to mention next is that
even you change this actually it's
possible you change the Assumption you
still have the same formula but on the
right hand side
so so you can have both you can like if
you change the Assumption maybe you
still have the same formula maybe you
still have a different formula so so
this is a comfort case which I think
that I think what I said is actually
even more surprising right so you change
the Assumption on the left hand side you
still have the same y given X on the
right hand side at least the same form
so so this is a example
so I guess here I'm looking at uh
I think one dimensional
so suppose X is one dimensional
just you know it's not very important
like exactly so so suppose you do x
given Y is one is from the so-called
poisson distribution
um wait how do I
personally distribution sorry
and then you do this
I must misspell this this works sorry
um but you do this so you change it's no
longer a gaussian it's um some other
distribution and
um oh I guess X is a is in because this
is a personal description so it has to
be integer something like integer
um and and then you still have y is uh P
of Y is one
is equals to V
right so we change our assumption
and then this actually still implies
that
P of Y given
X has this form one plus
e to the minus Theta transpose X plus
zero
so still the form looks similar of
course you know if you really numerical
computers it would be a different state
and say a zero because Theta and say
zero here I'm just writing them as a as
a generic variable right but actually
they are they are they are they have
meanings right Theta is a function of
Lambda one and lambda zero and so that
zero is also the function of unknown one
and lambda zero so the form is still
same
um but you could have like um numerical
if you if you use this model in terms of
instead of GDA you're gonna get
different state and zero so so a linear
form doesn't necessarily mean everything
right uh it also you know it also
depends on how you learn this linear
function so you have actually here we
have already three ways to learn it
where you can use this this model we can
use the GDA we can use the largest
equation they will all give you
different Theta and Theta 0 as a as a
final result and which one will be
better I think you know if you compare
GDA with this poisson version of the the
standard floating algorithm then I guess
the answer would be that you know
probably depends most on whether which
assumption is more correct more likely
to be correct of course there's also
some type thing here because here your
your thing is like and but suppose you
have a different model which also deal
with like R like you know if we
basically I'm saying like when you
compare it okay forget about this axis
in anything I suppose you don't care
about that differences then which model
will work better probably depends on
whether your assumption is correct or
not or which assumption is more likely
to be correct and and when you compare
the general following algorithm with the
discriminant one I think it's the same
thing right so if your generative
assumption is more is likely to be
correct then you should gain something
from it otherwise maybe you should just
use long distal question
I think in some sense like at these days
you know if you look at um
um and also another thing is that um
okay so
um
so and and also
um maybe a little more General
discussion is that
um in some sense your model has two
source of like a
so in some sense they are like in some
sense you have two sources of knowledge
the model learns from two things in some
sense so one thing is that your
assumption
and the other thing is you have data
right so the assumptions means like how
do I probabilistically model all of
these qualities and data is really just
what you see right so if you have more
data of course it's good right if you
have more assumption if the assumption
is correct then that's good
um but on the other hand suppose if for
example you have already a lot of data
then you have less need to use prior
knowledge because your data already are
very telling right so like the data is
kind of sufficient for you to to kind of
like extract whatever information you
want then you don't really need to use
prior knowledge because if you use prior
knowledge you always have a risk to use
it wrongly right so so basically in some
sense I think the more than
our trend is that you know like we're
going to talk about the new artworks and
deep learning um so in in two lectures
the Modern Trend is that now we're in
this setting that we have more and more
data for many applications
and and and then that's why the modern
techniques you know like deep learning
new artworks those techniques you know
use fewer and fewer assumptions about
our data
so just because you know it's not really
worth it right so like I have to think
about how do I model my images right
suppose you apply these two images right
you have to have a model for X for the
file image you know does it really work
the effort to do that you know probably
not you know of course it depends on
cases but if you just want to First Cut
results you don't have to model your X
because modern X is very difficult you
know it's very challenging and you may
make mistakes so so you probably should
just directly go for the more pull off
like a discriminative analysis type of
approach right so you just directly
model y given XP accessor image right
but in the in the um in some other
applications for example if you think
about medical applications right all or
some of the other applications of
machine learning
where you don't have enough data in
those cases I think still you have to
kind of use as much prior knowledge as
possible
um and actually many times people even
do even much more complicated modeling
of your ex right so maybe you can use
some other more advanced ways to model
your ex because you know how does each
chord of X what each coordinate of X
means and you know what's their
relationship and you put all of this
prior knowledge into your modeling for x
and then you get finally some wagon X
using this machinery and then you
predict and that's that's more likely to
work
so
um yeah I guess that's the that's
another thing is that if you use more
assumptions then you are specializing to
your application right that's another
reason probably why in the modern time
like people somehow don't do this kind
of use these paranoids that often
because I guess probably heard of me
right works and one of the kind of magic
about it is that it works for many many
cases without much customization right
if you use prior assumptions you'll use
more assumptions you you are you are
you have to kind of like use different
assumptions for different applications
because for different applications their
data probably have different structures
you so you have to do it one by one and
that's actually what people do
um a lot of times right so they look at
their domain their questions and and
study the structure
um but these days you know like as
you'll see like when people use device
works because you have enough data and
you just drop assumptions and you make a
model kind of very general not very not
specialized at all and you supply it to
everything just without thinking much
about what the data look like
so uh yeah so I guess that's a you know
you will talk more about new artworks
but this is the a preview or kind of
connections to what we're going to talk
about next
um another kind of like a big picture is
that you know one of the reasons as I
said you know in some sense I I was
saying that you know this kind of GDA
analysis is not used that often
um at least not used as often as before
right before you have to use these kind
of things and now you can at least you
have the choice to uh to try something
like works and and because you have more
data so
um but still I think if you are able to
model the ax you know in many cases you
can do better so and also in some cases
you just don't have why so even even for
example when you have images right so
sometimes you don't have why at all you
just only have X and in those cases you
just really have to model X because
that's the only place where you can get
information from it and another
possibility another cases is um uh we
are going to talk about languages right
like uh especially like this lecture I'm
going to talk about language as well but
you know later when we're also going to
talk about languages you know solving
language problems with new artworks and
they are you know you're just getting a
kind of a
um like a lot of like text from the from
the internet right and there's no labels
there's no way nobody's tell you like
which like which web page is is about
which right so you just have like raw
attacks you don't only have acts and in
those cases you really have to model X3
there's no way you can get around this
so so so so still like modeling acts is
is very important it's just like um for
example it's less important for certain
kind of applications because we have
more data
any questions
thank you
Okay cool so I guess so now I'm going to
move on to
um the next uh uh the next uh question
so um I think the the question is this
the so-called one
on classification
so you are trying to understand whether
a piece of tax is a spam email or not
right so like you have an email spam
filter and you want to know whether your
email is a spam or not and we're still
going to do generative learning
algorithm
and and we're gonna have this great ax
so this is another example how you do
this challenge for learning algorithm
your model X given Y and you execute
this like a pipeline in some sense and
and learn something out of it
okay so
um
so the first thing so I'm going to you
know get into a little more details you
know how do we really approach this
question
so the first thing you probably have to
what okay
these are just examples
um
right so I guess um
um so the first question uh to a first
question we have to do to approach this
is that how do you represent a text
right attacks are symbols right like a
ABCD right so
um you need to make a numerical at least
to to to to to to make the computer
recognize them right so to in some in
some naive way at least right so so the
question first question is how do you
change the tax
to some you know
acts maybe you call this feature right
this is a
um You can call this feature vector or
or representation or something like that
so you want to change this to X in some
Dimension d e and then you model X
so so first question is how to represent
text so there are many ways to represent
text so
um so the way I'm going to tell you is a
very naive way this is like a
um a probably I shouldn't say naive like
but this is like a very simple way like
uh on this stage we're gonna have like a
you know if you really deal with the
taxi you're gonna use a more advanced
deep learning based approach which we're
going to cover a little bit in the in
probably
three or five weeks so um
so this way so here the way that we do
it is very simple so what you do is that
um
maybe I should have some
so what you do is you say you have you
first look at the vocabulary
suppose you have a vocabulary of maybe
10K words
so and suppose you say you list all of
these words in your sequence based on
alphabetical order I guess if if you
open up a dictionary the first letter
the first word is for probably always a
I think the second you know
are coming to
some dictionary the second word is this
word otherwalk I think it's a kind of
animal
um and the third one is uh the wolf I
think it's another kind of animal
something like this and then you list
all the words you know and maybe at some
point you're gonna have a word book and
eventually the last word I think in many
of the dictionary is this
this thing I don't even know how to
I don't even remember how to
pronounce it I think I used to know when
the first time I teach this lecture and
then I forgot after a few years
um anyway so you listed all of this and
and then you say that
um
um you have suppose you have a piece of
text right so
maybe say
suppose you have a sentence
or maybe an email suppose this email
just has one sentence uh something like
I buy a book
so you want to turn this into a vector
and how do you turn it into a vector so
the way that we do it here is that you
turn it in a vector that is of dimension
um this axis of Dimension d
where let's say d is the size of the
vocabulary T is equals to the number of
words
so and then on this Vector that
represents
um
piece of uh this sentence is going to be
a zero one vector so X is actually
you know it's really from 0 1 to the
power d
there are only two choices and every
entry so you have so many entries and
what you do is you say if this word
shows up in the sentence then you have
entry one in this entry so the word a
shows up in the sentence then I have one
here and the artwork doesn't show up in
that sense sometimes I have zero and
then
at some point you have this
corresponding entry book the book shows
up in the sentence I have one here and
maybe somewhere I think there's a word
probably I here in the list and then
that
one would also have a one that that word
also corresponds to one and for all the
other entries that all the other words
that don't show up
uh in the sentence you just fill in zero
for the corresponding entries
so and you call this x your
representation or your feature Vector uh
for uh for for this email for this
sentence
so basically technically I'm just going
to say that x i is equals to one
if and only if
uh the ith word
occurs
in the email
so there are actually many other ways to
encode even before you know using deep
learning techniques
um but but this is probably one of the
simplest one and you can see that this
this representation of the sentence is
in some sense like a super
um I guess like simplistic because for
example you don't care about the orders
of the world right suppose you have
another sentence I a book by right that
sentence still has the same
representation just exactly the same and
it doesn't care about the frequency of
the word for example suppose I have a
sentence I buy a book and
a a kind of pencil
then of course the the representation
will change but this two word a and a
here you know will be kind of you will
still have a work according one here
it's because the word a shows up in this
sentence but you don't care about how
many times the word a
shows up in the sentence
so so you don't care about the frequency
of the words in this sentence you just
care about whether each word shows up
so um and you know there are many other
proper issues with this like uh what
else
um
yeah I guess probably these two are the
most important thing where you don't
have to order and you don't have you
don't care about the frequency
um but that's what we're going to deal
with because this is easy and you can
um somewhere kind of like do all of the
math uh with this kind of model
Okay so
now
what's the next question
the next question is that we need to
build a generative model for X gaming y
and we need to have a model for y and
then we do mle and we solve the
parameter so and so forth
so
[Applause]
so basically I think I can just erase
this and now I'm going to redefine
experience
right so that's what I'm gonna do
okay so let's take um and how do you
proceed so
now because this x now is a binary
Vector it's only taking 0 and 1. so you
need a distribution that can generate
binary vectors
right so you cannot use gaussian here
um and the kind of the techniques that
we are using here is the so-called naive
layers
so what does this mean is that
um this means that you just assume
Max 1 up to XD
or maybe I'll erase this you know
are independent
conditions on
y
so given y you just independently draw
exponent after x d of course this is not
realistic right this is definitely not
exact you know how realistic it is I
think that's subjective but at least
this is not exactly how people generate
emails right you are not saying that I'm
going to generate a spam filter I first
decide I'm going to generate generate a
spamming email and the first thing I
decide is I decide why and then after I
decide why I just trying to reward
randomly like like right that's probably
not what how how people write
spam emails right so and also that's not
how people write the the usual like good
emails
so
um but it turns out that many in many
cases these kind of assumptions are
pretty
um already pretty good so in the
homework actually
um actually we haven't decided whether
we are going to include that homework
question but at least you know there are
there are cases where
um you can see this kind of things can
be very effective right actually if you
just really use this model even you make
this kind of crazy assumption and you
learn some parameters and use this model
to expect on classified spams I think
you're going to get more than 90
accuracy maybe these days you know as of
like a 20 2012 maybe it's not that
effective because all the the spammers
they are they are adversarial right so
they know what your prediction algorithm
is they can change their algorithm to
kind of fool you but but at least this
is a reasonable one if you go back 10
years ago for sure like
so
um so so it's kind of interesting right
so even you make
you know obviously kind of not exactly
the right assumption but sometimes you
can still because the Assumption
problems somewhat correct you know to
some extent you can still get a useful
kind of outcome from it
and for our purpose I think here
um I guess you know to some extent I'm
not really that
um
I don't care that much about assumptions
I think it's more like I'm trying to
demonstrate the methodology
um like how how do you like I just want
to give a new example where you execute
this probabilistic model this flow this
this pipeline right um and show how how
to solve them
one example
right so the question is how how does
the text the lens of the text matter
right so here
um in so one interesting about this is
that in this representation the lens of
the text doesn't really matter you can
encode any lens into a vector of
Dimension d
which is you know you can say this is a
good thing or bad thing you know
um
um but but so so basically you can
encode any lens
um any sentence or any documents into a
single vector and how do you how to
decide which uh what is the window size
you know here I don't think it matters
that much maybe you just take entire
email
um yeah of course you know if you change
the the the I think I think you should
you should just include the entire email
because that's the the unit you are
working with right like for every email
you are classifying whether it's a Spam
or not you are not classifying it
whether a sentence is of spam or not so
that's why you treat an email as a
single example
okay all right
x12x3. does that mean that like
if you want like One X appears that
tells us nothing about whether another X
is likely to appears or does it mean
that all X's are equally likely to
appear
like one y material
um I think it's it's more about the it's
more the first okay so so because I do
like certainly not all the words are
equally likely to appear right so I so
basically I'm assuming that given y
given you have decided that which
whether this is spam email or not
um every word you know is is uh is they
are they are independent with each other
but but they they may have different
kind of probability
[Applause]
okay so I guess let me proceed so
so what does this really mean okay now
I'm going to do some math right so to
kind of expand this and parametricize it
so this really means that you have this
P of X1 give an XT
given y you write this as P of X1 given
y times P of x d given y
and now I I can I just need to
parameterize each of this problem
distribution by some parameter so and if
you think about this what is this uh
this is this is really just the
distribution of Bernoulli distribution
because X I can only have two Choice
zero one so basically you just have to
describe this probability by two numbers
right I'm actually by one number right
so so basically what you do is that you
parametrize
parameters
of the model is you have
fee
on say j
so there's some in the index which I'm
going to explain in a moment
you
say this is x j is equals to one given
Y is equal to one so basically for y is
equal to one you're asking you know
what's the probability of x j is one
right and you you denote that
probability as this
and then once you have this you know the
probability
of x j is equals to zero
given Y is 1 is going to be one minus v
j given Y is one and this uh this um
this thing is just a notation it's not
like a
um it's equally the same if I write J
comma one
uh I just like I write this subscript
because it's a little bit more intuitive
but it but I just I just need an index
in some sense doesn't make sense
so basically for every J I'm going to
have a parameter for either J and and
one I'm gonna have a parameter that's
called Phi and this parameter is in 0 1.
right so and and this parameter describe
this distribution
and for y is zero I'm also going to have
a parameter so so I'm going to write
this as J given y zero so this is the
parameter for
the distribution of x j
given y zero
yes it's between 0 and 1.
this is between this is inter this is uh
the bracket uh the hardback
okay
okay so so basically I'm saying that if
I this with this parameter and this
parameter I can describe
all the all of this I can I can write
out all of these numbers because I I
describe all the quantities right
because for example what is p of x j
given actually 0 given y zero
this is going to be equals to 1 minus V
j y is zero
okay so and then I also have need to
have a
a
like something for this to parameterize
the description of Y we call that we
call this V before right in in the in
the GDA case and not just for the for
the sake of like a distinguishing it
from the other fees I'm going to call it
v y but this is the this serves as the
same row as fee uh in before in a GDA
case
any questions
foreign
[Applause]
of the parameters and you and this is
the probability of the data given the
parameters so what are the parameters
the parameters of v y is one of the
parameters and also all of these fees VJ
given y 0 and v j given Y is one so
basically I have V1 given y zero
up to 3D given y 0
and then fee one given Y is one
to Phi d y is y
right these are all your parameters
so
on my likelihood you know
here there are two
um uh waste I can expand this so the
first thing is that because by
definition the likelihood is the product
of the likelihood of each of the example
because your all your examples are
independent this is not naive place yet
this is the examples I implement so you
can just write this as probability of x
i y i
given all the parameters
and here if you are careful then you
know uh okay so it's basically all the
time I guess all the parameters I'm
going to write
I think in my notes the notation is this
so but I think this really just means
this is uh just a convenience notation
that denotes all of the parameters this
is the same as this
um okay and then
you
first you so so far is the same as the
GDA and then you can also do the chain
rule
to make this x i given y i
conditional parameters
okay given the parameters and then times
P of Y
I
gave me the parameters
so when I use dot dot dots I just mean
all the parameters of course sometimes
you can drop some parameters because
they are not they don't matter
and then I'm going to again factorize in
the dimension of X Y now I'm going to
use my
G like this naive face assumption right
which is the factorization across the
coordinates of X right we call that this
is x sub I is the coordinate of X the
superscript I is the iso example
so
so what I'm going to do is that I'm
going to use that assumption for each of
the examples so what I'm going to cut is
uh I from 1 to n
I'm going to put this in front just to
make a simple make it easier
um
and if I'm careful I I only have to
write Phi right here because the
description y only depends on v y and
then I'm going to factorize this thing
across the coordinates so I'm going to
have a product
um across the corners have D coordinates
and then I have P of x
sub j i
is the gist coordinate of the ice
example given the label for that Y is
example and all the parameters V
j y
just means
I guess maybe I'll just uh
so v j y this just means a shorthand for
this family of parameters
as a mix maybe I was just sorry this is
a bad notation
um
so v j y just means a shorthand for this
collection of parameters
Okay so
[Applause]
um
[Music]
so you mean here
um
yeah that's right so right if you only
look at
Yep this J and this J yes you only care
about the
you just care about the j under there's
the fixed j under the Y is 0 and Y
Square that's
great yeah
right so so so we have two times that we
factorize this probability so so the
first time is here
so here I'm using the fact that all the
all the examples are independently
sampled so that's why I I see the drawn
probability is the overall examples is
is the product of the probabilities of
each of the example I know for every
example
um of course I first do the chain rule
to get x given y That's and then I
factorize this one into this product
again and this is the level of the knife
phase this is using native phase
Okay cool so
and then so I guess you can expect you
know what we're going to do we're going
to maximize this and we know that if you
add maximize this it's the same as
maximize suppose that's called this L
right so max minus L this is the same as
Arc Max
of log l
and log l
is going to be a sum of the log of this
probability so log l
will be a sum
you turn all of this to sum and you have
to log in in front of the terms right so
you have log
p y I can v y Plus
here we have a double sum sum over I
from one to n sum over J from 1 to D and
the log of this
and then you analytically plug in all of
this right so for example for this one
you can you know what is this right this
is equals to
what is this this is equals to
v y if y i is one if this is equal to
one minus v y if Y is equal to zero
right so and for each of this you can
write them as a formula or for of the
data and the and the parameters and then
you you do the maximum likelihood so the
maximum likelihood uh I guess I'll also
just tell you the solution
um
so if you write look at the gradient of
l
is zero right this is the
right this is the con it's a sufficient
it's a necessary condition for for you
you are being failed to be a maximizer
okay I should write
why
and you compute this gradient and you
solve this equation this is a family of
equations and then this solving it
gives
um some formulas for the parameters on
your recovering so the so the final
solution will look like this v y is
equals to
um
right
this is pretty intuitive this is the
fraction
of positive examples
actually it's the same formula as we
have seen for the GDA
and then fee
j y is one this is the probability to
see XJ is one given Y is one it turns
out that this is also something simple
so you look at
maybe let me write down the formula and
then interpret it
so what is this numerator this is the
number of occurrences
of ice word right
it's only one when
the eighth word the ice example contains
the J's word right so the J's word right
this is x j i is one means that the J's
word shows up in the ith example
in and and you also require that the iso
example is positive example so basically
the sum is the total number of
currencies of jth word
in positive examples
and
and this is the number of positive
examples
so you can see that you know even though
we have done a lot of like calculation
and modeling identify the the formula is
pretty intuitive you are in sometimes
just counting it's kind of like
something about counting right you're
doing some statistics right you're
counting how many times the jsword shows
up in positive examples and you divide
that by how many total parts of examples
they are right so for example suppose
like the word book shows up in
10 positive examples and they are they
are like a medium positive samples that
means this is five over a minute
which kind of means that book doesn't
seem to have much correlation with past
examples if it is this number is smaller
if this number is small it means that
it's unlikely to see the J's word get
impossible
so when it's unlikely you know it's
unlikely because partly because the data
they don't show up
so
okay and for the negative examples is
the same so
you just the right to
um it's kind of symmetric so feel of J
given y 0 is equals to
on something like
I guess you can guess what the what it
is right basically just
change every the value of y to
zero
and any questions
[Applause]
okay so
um okay so basically we are done with
this
um at least uh we are almost done
there's one small thing that we have to
address but in terms of the isometer
parameter we are done
so and we got a parameter another
prediction time as before right so we'll
do the prediction
as as usual you want to compute P of Y
is 1 given X
right and if this number is larger than
0.5 then you say this is a positive
example if this number is less than 0.5
you say this is an active example so we
have to compute this and how do we
compute this you know this is
again
as in our general methodology use the
base rule
and divide by P of x
so this is still the same
but there is one small caveat here which
is that what if you have a zero divided
by zero in situation
so before we have gaussian the density
no matter what you do the density is
always non-zero at every places even
though sometimes it could be very small
the density could be very small but
still your PX in all of these quantities
are
like all positive it's strictly positive
at least you're gonna get the ratio here
but here there might be some cases where
your P of X is just literally zero
and why that can happen I guess maybe
let me just give you an example so so
you may think that some example just
never shows up just because of some
um I guess let me show the exam cases
right so suppose maybe let's say suppose
so suppose
um
maybe the word artwork
never appears
in in changing side
I never claim that this would mean that
this would mean that P if you have a but
your test example
content continent
so let's say Test example let's call it
X contains it and now I'm going to claim
that P of X will be considered as 0.
um why I guess let's um some will
simulate this algorithm and see what the
fee will we're going to compute from
this
so
otherwise hard work is the second word
right so your so J is 2.
so
um and you know x2j X2
I is zero for every eye
this is a mathematical translation of
for every example the second word never
shows up that's why the x2i is zero and
when the X2 is 0 and you plug in it into
this formula that tries to estimate this
parameter suppose let's try to ask me
the parameter V
two Y is one right this Parliament
intuity means that How likely the second
word will show up in a positive example
and recall that you know this formula is
really about you know
the total number of occurrences that is
where shows up and divided by total
number of positive examples so this will
be zero because
no occurrences of the second word
divided by the total number of positive
examples
and this will be zero that's still fine
um so far it's not a problem so zero
divided by a positive number that's fine
and the feed to y 0 is the same 0 over
total number of negative examples
this is also zero
so so basically according to your uh
estimate male estimate this this word
otherwise just cannot show up at all
right which makes sense because they
didn't so it didn't show up in the
tuning side you know you you just you
know estimate you also say it shouldn't
show up at all in this under this uh
this set of parameters
so but that's that's a problem because
now if you compute
P of x
for example X it does contain the the
second word then you're gonna write this
as P of X so how to compute this you use
the the total law of probability you say
this is equals to
case when Y is one plus the case when
y0
and
of course this is a positive number this
is a positive number that's fun but this
one is equals to
maybe I'll just this one is equals to
the using naive base this is equal to x
j you know Y is one and you have some a
product over J from J to
d
right and now I know that my X2
is one because this word does show up in
this email and that means that P
you're gonna have P of X2 equals to 1
given Y is one
as the second term in this product
right so you're going to have this term
shows up in this product but this one is
equals to Phi 2 Y is 1 which is equal to
zero
so just because of the second word you
know according to your model is not
supposed to show up but it does show up
that means that this example just does
have zero probability and your
probabilistic model so that's why this
is zero
and for the same reason so this one is
going to be equals to
y0
and also you have this term P of X2
equals to 1 given y 0.
and we call that under a probabilistic
model you learned you just think this
word cannot show up at all right the
chance is zero so that's why the chance
to see this word shows up is zero so
this is zero so that's why this is also
zero so because the zero terms
eventually I guess if you
because there's a zero here there's a
zero here so you get zero just
eventually
so basically you conclude that this
example which is
n't supposed to show up like this
example has zero probability under this
probabilistic model that you you learn
so and then that's a problem because now
this P of X is a zero this is zero
so you have something divided by zero
actually this is also zero if you think
about it because this is just the one
term
the numerator is just one term in the
decomposition of PX when the numerator
is just this term
and a p x is the sum of the two terms so
both of these the numerator and the
denominator they are both zero and you
have the zero divided by zero situation
and now and what you do so this is a
this is the issue and this is a
reasonably realistic issue because
sometimes you just see a new word in
your test example right you haven't seen
this word at all in the tuning site
so on the way we deal with this is
so-called uh LaPlace and smoothing
in some sense this is a way to introduce
a little bit prior
so that you don't 100 trust your
training site so so basically what we
are seeing here is that you trust your
trainings are just 100 like religiously
in some sense like a like a like you uh
you haven't seen any word the other the
word artwork right in the tuning side
you just and because of that you trust
it you just say this word the students
show up at all that's why if you see
this if this word is in this ax right so
then the probability of X is to zero so
so what we are going to do is we're
going to say okay just uh you know maybe
we shouldn't trust the data exactly
we're gonna allow it to allow any new
word to show up a little bit with some
small chance and and it's in some sense
this is a local adjustment
um
um by using some prior knowledge which
is called LaPlace
foreign
just to
the best way to describe this method is
start with something abstract
um
for the moment let's forget about that
for the moment and just think about the
abstract question suppose you have
um
so simple simple example maybe you can
call this example or abstraction in some
sense so suppose you think about you
know your estimate
um
the bias of the bias of a chord
right suppose you have a call and this
coin is biased it's not 50 50.
um so how do you know the the bias of
the chord or in mathematical language it
really means that you have a random
variable Z which is from Bernoulli
um where with a parameter fee and this
fee is something unknown right it's not
the half and you want to know what the
fee is and you want to know it by
looking at some data right so you draw a
few copies from this distribution and
you want to know what's the
um
uh what's the what was feed you want to
ask me feedback
um by using the data and you want to
solve this problem right this is still a
probabilistic model we can still do the
same thing where you can write out a
probabilistic you can write out the mle
and you can write out the you can
maximize the Moe right so let's uh maybe
let's try to do this just uh so suppose
you have like maybe n trials
and let's call this you know Z1
Z2
and z and and each of these is either
one or zero something like this
right or maybe I can see my nose is
called tail has
so I'll just continue
something like this
so and you want to estimate what fee is
and if you follow our general principle
right we'll try to write out the
likelihood then the likelihood
what is the likelihood
foreign
so the likelihood
of fee right of the parameter fee
um is the chance to see this data set
given the parameter fee so what's the
chance to see this data set the chance
to see the first one is one minus V
right a chance to see the second one is
is one um I guess tail means
I think I need to Define Teo means what
tail means zero let's say
has means one
right so
so the chance to and you have a uh the
the the probability to see one is Phi
and probability c0 is one minus V so
that's why the probability of to see the
first example is one minus V and then
you time one minus FIFA second example
when you multiply a bench and then you
multiply fee at the end right this is
the left node and and if you organize
this right you count how many one minus
V they are how many speeds they are this
will be one minus V
to the power of
the number of uh
uh tails
and times V
to pause
actually if you really look at this
example you will see that the formulas
are very very similar actually this
example is a toy case for that in some
sense
um okay so you get this and then you can
um take the arc Max of this like log
likelihood you take the arc Max of the
log likelihood so the arc Max
uh maybe let's call this
IO fee
so the arc Max of log of LV
if you solve it you are going to get the
following so it's going to be the number
of
has
over the number of
has plus the number of tails
which also makes sense because you know
this is basically empirical frequency of
seeing the house
I just mean like the the frequency of
that you see that has in the in the
tuning set right and that's your most
likely estimate for uh for fee Okay so
and
[Applause]
right so
so okay so far everything seems to make
sense right so but now let's consider a
somewhat
um kind of extreme case
so what if you see
all the examples you see are Tails right
and you don't have a lot of like suppose
you just have three Jaws Z1 Z2 and Z3
and they are all tail
so according to this formula you're
gonna get on the fee the best estimate
for V is 0 over 0 plus 3 which is equals
to zero
but
you should do really trust this right so
if you do really trust that this this
coin just never give you a hat
right what does this mean this means
that this coin just never give you a hat
at all forever right she didn't really
trust that
um you know this is a little bit
subjective right you mean you know if
you are really really trust the data you
probably can say yes but you know maybe
you have some prior knowledge that most
of the coins are not that crazy right so
like you probably should at least have
some chance to see the hat right with
some chance
so
um so in some sense you can say so
basically on the flip side you can say
okay maybe this is some coincidence
right it just happens that you see
storytelles even this fee is a half
right seeing this example seeing these
cases is the problem to see this case is
is at least one over eight right it's
something like one rate so so maybe it's
just Coincidence of the data set
so maybe you shouldn't trust the data
sets that much
um so the so-called Law plus smoothing
is is a way to in some sense incorporate
a prior so that you you say look my coin
shouldn't be extreme shouldn't be too
extreme like this so so basically if the
LaPlace moving refers to the following
estimator
so this if you use a plastic smoothing
you're gonna have a different formula
your fee will be equals to the number of
heads
plus 1 over a number of heads
plus the number of tails
plus two
so this formula you know you know I
didn't tell you any like a mathematical
justification actually if you really
look in the literature they are
mathematical justifications so far I'm
just determining the formula but it
would solve this problem right like at
least to some extent because for this
particular case
you are gonna get
one on on the numerator and four
um for the denominator so instead of
getting zero you're getting one over
four so still you you say okay the
chance to see the head is pretty small
right it's smaller than the chance to
see the tail but you don't have a very
extreme estimate
so and and you can see that this LaPlace
moving is mostly useful when you have
not enough data right if you have a lot
of data then this plus boosting is not
doing much right maybe let me give you a
kind of a
example for example suppose you have a
big data
where the number of has let's say
I guess I'm making up this right so 100
a number of tails
is 60.
so if you use the standard approach
right if you use the the
the standard approach or maybe I
shouldn't call like the vanilla approach
then this is like a the fee would be
equals to 60 over 60 plus
100.
right this is
uh what is this this is like a
I don't know what I say like this is
something like this and then
um if you use the LaPlace smoothing
then this fee will be 60 plus 1 over 60
plus 100 plus 2
which will be
um 61 over 162. this is 60 over one 60.
and these two are just those very
similar just because the one
whatever you change here one two right
it doesn't really matter that much
because the the dominating term is the
six and a hundred
so so sometimes you you achieve a like
you choose you achieve a kind of right
balance right if you have enough data
then you're prior or like your LaPlace
missing is not doing much it doesn't
really change much you trust your data
and if you don't have enough data then
La plasma thing would um would try to
make it not too extreme we'll try to
make your estimate not too extreme
okay
[Applause]
so now let's go back to our problem so
let me see where is the best way to
provide this
um
oh I think I erased them
oh I erased the formula but I'll write
it again
foreign
[Applause]
so going back to our spam filtering
thing I guess actually there is a there
is a there's one thing that is left here
this is our estimate
right and our other estimate was
something like VJ wise one is equals to
am I writing the super
super I think this is I not that
right so if you apply this to uh our
case so you can recall that you know in
this case it's kind of like you are
saying that
the numerator is the number of times
this word shows up in a positive example
and and
the denominator is like the total number
of positive examples right so in some
sense the knowledge is that this
denominator is very similar to the
number of heads and tails because
because the health means that this word
shows up that tail means this word
doesn't show up so and and here the the
denominator is like the total number of
times the total number of examples
positive examples
um and here the the the the numerator is
the kind of like the has right so
basically has means that the words show
up in positive in a positive example and
tail means that the word doesn't show up
in a positive example so that's why this
is like has number of heads and this is
second number of has a plus number of
Tails and if you use a lot plus more
thing then
um you're gonna add one to the
denominator and you add to the numerator
and you add two to the denominator
so that's the that's the LA possible
and the same thing for the other
formulas you're gonna get add one
and I2 here
so that's the uh LaPlace moving
and while this solves our problem it
solves our problem because now we just
never
phone we just never estimate any
parameter fee to be exactly zero right
so recall that when we have this uh
um
artwork issue right so the issue was
that these two parameters for the
artwork
was exactly zero
um yeah let me ask
um
that's a fantastic question so the
question was that whether you want to do
the same possible thing for the fee why
like fee why was the single scaler to
describe the the problems of why
um
to describe the uh the probability of
each of the class right so and you are
right so suppose one class just never
shows up right and you still only have
like negative class of positive cost
then you probably should use LaPlace
missing for that but I think this is a
little bit less important because you
know in most of the data set you have to
see positive examples and negative
samples you have to see a reasonable
number of maybe 50 of positive negative
and then LaPlace moving wouldn't really
matter that much you can still use it
but it wouldn't matter that much
okay so going back to this so
so recall that our problem was that when
you have the when you have the
parameters you get this zero right you
you thought that other boxes shouldn't
show up at all right because it's very
extreme estimate and now when you add
this one and two here
on on so what you're gonna happen is
that instead of having zero over the
number of positive examples you get zero
plus one over this plus two
yeah I don't have a different color
sorry so I have to just modify
um
um I just only have black pants
um but so you get this and then this
will be at least no longer so this will
be still a pretty small number right
this is one over the number of positive
example
plus two so but at least this is bigger
than zero
so and the same thing for this right so
you're gonna get plus one
our
on this plus two and this is bigger than
zero
so if both of these are bigger than zero
then when you evaluate this formula you
are not going to evaluate to zero so
your P of X will be some positive number
so then you can get a a number of the P
of bike effects
and maybe just a very small extension
give you have two minutes so two or
three minutes so if you have more than
two classes
you can
um this is just a
for your interest
um so suppose you have like a
maybe a dice something like that right
instead of like a coin so suppose you
have Z which is
from something like zero one up to K
minus one so you have K choices then uh
the LA plus the general LaPlace
smoothing would be something like if you
don't do LaPlace moving what you're
gonna have is that the pro the chance
you estimate this
to be
something like the number of times
z i is equals to J
over the total number of examples so you
count how many examples kind of end up
to the choice J and you divide by the
total number of examples and if you use
LaPlace moving you're gonna add one to
the top and you add K to the bottom
where K is the number of choices so so
this is just a small extension of
Laplace smoothing
you know I don't think this course will
use it again but
for your interest
um okay cool I guess that's pretty much
all for today any questions
okay great yeah in the next lecture I
guess so we're going to talk about the
kernel method and then we're going to
talk to deep learning